if you had to pick one marvel character
to babysit for you
would you pick captain america iron man
or nick fury
oh gosh i kind of feel like this is a
no-brainer
um are the are these the actual
characters the or the people that play
them
oh my gosh i want now i want i knew you
were going to go with captain america
who doesn't go with captain america so
who are you going to pick in real life
in real life i would probably pick
uh i'd probably go with sam okay yeah
i trust them so much yeah i know
we work together i i mean i trust all
those guys so much but
worked with them all of them for such a
long time um
but you know sam's like he would be able
to he's just been there
he has his own grown daughter he's he
he's he's got it figured out i would
totally trust him with
and she my most precious most precious
piece of my heart i would trust in sam
for sure and she your daughter would
also know the f-bomb like within seconds
so it's amazing
[Laughter]
yep i'm still here just waiting for you
to subscribe
if you don't i'll be trapped in this box
forever